until recently the vast majority of the
world population worked on farms and the
total production of the world's economy
was mostly the total agricultural output
and this output was limited by the fixed
size of the land the total output of the
economy did not change a lot year by
year the size of the pie was fixed the
world was a zero-sum game in such a
stagnating world the only way to get
better off is if someone else gets worse
off if you take a bigger piece of the
pie someone else's gets smaller if you
want more food then conquering
plundering and stealing are great
strategies your neighbours loss is your
gain this was the state of things for
thousands of years societies invaded
each other constantly to get more pie
economic inequality was extreme some had
all the pie they wanted while others had
to live with the crumbs then the
Industrial Revolution happened and
everything changed we developed
machinery better crops better
fertilizers agricultural output
skyrocketed but we didn't just produce
more food every industrial sector
exploded in terms of productivity from
1700 to 1870 the production of iron in
Britain increased 137 fold the
Industrial Revolution led to a
previously unimaginable increase in
economic output this altered the nature
of our societies
economic growth changed the world from a
zero-sum game to a positive sum game we
had found a way to create a bigger pie
but not only a bigger pie but a pie that
was growing bigger each year more people
could have more at the same time this
development is spreading and continuing
today antibiotics kill bacteria power
plants deliver energy cell phones
connect us planes let us travel cheaply
fridges store food continuous progress
in all sectors of the economy seems
normal to us today but the change from
stagnation to economic growth rarely was
the most drastic shift in human history
how was this possible at the very core
of this massive transformation stand new
ideas that lead to innovation innovation
has many different definitions but in
the context of this video we mean better
solutions to existing problems and
solutions to problems we didn't know we
had the more you innovate the more
complex and interesting problems you
discover as your wishes and needs evolve
the average citizen in Norway 250 years
ago might have wanted some very good
shoes 150 years ago maybe a bicycle 80
years ago a car 30 years ago
cheap air travel and so on once we get
what we want we don't stop we can see
how we can improve things even more and
how to make things even better the new
positive-sum world has existed for 0.1%
of human history and we have yet to get
used to it it has a consequence that
feels really unintuitive in a positive
some world it's in your personal selfish
best interest that every human on planet
earth is well off it's good for you if
people in obscure parts of countries
you've never heard of of prospering
there is a genuine selfish argument for
making the world a better place in a
positive some world the more people are
well-off the better your own life is
this is because of the nature of
innovation it is fundamentally driven by
supply and demand the supply increases
when more people have the freedom and
education to contribute they become
inventors researchers engineers or
thinkers that come up with new ideas the
demand Friday's increases as people get
richer and can pay for new solutions
they increase the size of the market for
innovations
innovation follows incentives for so
naturally if many people want and can
pay for something it will get the
innovators attention and energy
improving the lives of those who are
worst off has a multiplying effect it
increases demand for ideas while at the
same time making it easier for ideas to
be produced let's take an example that
interests all of us a cure for cancer if
there are 1 billion people in the world
that have the wealth to pay for cancer
treatments innovation will follow this
demand so hundreds of billions of
dollars have been invested in medical
research this had a huge effect but was
still nowhere near to curing all forms
of cancer today every sixth person in
the world dies of cancer and you might
be one of them now imagine if demand
were higher imagine instead of 1 billion
people being able to pay for a cure for
cancer there were 4 billion or 7 billion
imagine how far medicine could have
developed if we invested 7 times as much
in curing cancer on top of that there's
so much human potential being wasted
right now the work of a poor farmer in a
developing nation is not useful to you
but if he becomes better off his
children might spend their time in
university developing things that are
useful to you instead of having some
hotspots of innovation in the developed
world we would have many hotspots all
over the world the research output of
humanity would be many times what it is
right now could we have cured cancer by
now if that were the case well maybe if
we spent 7 times as much on research had
7 times as many people working on it and
a global network of medical research
things would certainly be further ahead
than they are now and this is the core
of the argument the more people want the
same thing that you want the more likely
you are to get it that is what it means
to live in a positive some world you
don't gain more pie if poor places stay
poor instead you get more pie if poor
places get richer contribute ideas and
grow the global pie which you like space
travel imagine there were billions of
people in Africa and Asia with their own
space programs
and demand for satellites and moon bases
and cities on Mars do you like being a
life a few billion people paying for
medical research could literally save
your life it's in your interest for
people around the world to become better
off the faster we get to this version of
the world the better for you personally
no matter what your motivation is
working on a better world is a very good
thing to do for others and for you this
video was in collaboration with Max Rosa
and our world in data and supported by
the Billa Melinda Gates Foundation if
you want to help us stay afloat to make
more videos you can support us on
patreon or get some of our fancy posters